with the kid i'm only going to choke
with the ken we do these
spurs
and we try and get the pieces right
but what we're doing is like the walking
this morning in there we're thinking
about
getting it correct but a lot of it we're
doing
there's a blank
and we might then make a mistake
and it destroys us for a moment so you
pull yourself together
hey ah
and then you try harder because you've
just made a mistake so you pull yourself
together
so you've then added another problem
because you've then added power
you've added strength you've added want
you've added lots of problems into the
suburi
you can't find coke you you know this
this super power you can't find coke you
until you're relaxed
so when i do this
i've been doing it so long but so are
some of you
you should actually just be doing it you
know you thought about what you're going
to do
and then you should just do it if you
keep looking for criticizing yourself if
it's right wrong
feeling good or bad it will it won't
come
because as i say you will either add
strength you'll add want
desire you'll add all these things that
shouldn't be in there
hence cytosense is saying tony the
technique is strong
you don't have to be what he's saying is
don't add anything
just do a saburi
is an act of swinging a wooden sword
what do we add to it we had thinking
criticism we're adding all these pieces
and it's very difficult to say don't add
them because how do you get it right
well you get it right by criticism
thinking right so
so if you can have a piece of paper and
cut it in half and so you hold that
and when i've got this half done i'll
then look at that half
so most of you have been doing aikido
long enough now
that
okay yeah i'm happy with that now can i
have that paper
where's the bit paper i'll give you this
is blank
and that's the bit you want you want the
blank
piece of paper after you've done
all the criticizing the want the desire
the time then you add in the coke you
so what is coke coke you is joy
coke you is expense so
sebastian i thought put it really well
when you expand when am i gonna expand
so now i'm starting to think about it so
i'm now going to destroy
because i'm going to start thinking do i
add it now
if i ended it then that means that would
be power or that would be one that would
be desired
yeah but when do i put it in sensei tell
me when to put it in and i'll put it in
well you should have already put it in
but i hadn't done nothing yet since
i said well that's the time to put it in
isn't it before you do anything
right so to find coke you
as i'm going to get my ken i'm going to
expand
i'm now expanding like sebastian said
and i'm expanding
let's just say for this argument i only
expand to that green
container i'll expand here
to you i'll expand to the fence
[Music]
and then i'm going to just cut blankly
i'm gonna criticize myself because i
squeezed a bit hard at the end
so tony still had to get involved there
very difficult to find